[موسيقى] مرحبًا ،
أنا الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا ، مضيف
بث بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN ،
هناك مفهوم خاطئ شائع
يعتقد الكثيرون أن فقدان البصر مع
تقدمك في العمر أمر مفروغ منه ، فلا يمكنك ويجب أن تفعل
كل ما في وسعك للحفاظ على بصرك
إذا كنت تدخن  حاول الإقلاع عن التدخين هناك
العديد من الدراسات التي وجدت أن المدخنين أكثر
عرضة للإصابة بالضمور البقعي بمرتين إلى أربع مرات مقارنة بالأشخاص
الذين لم يسبق لهم تناول
سيجارة ،
كما أنهم يمارسون الرياضة بانتظام
والحفاظ على وزن صحي يمكن أن يساعد في
منع مرض السكري الرخيص الذي يسبب
ضعف البصر الذي يمكن أن  تؤدي إلى العمى ،
تذكر أخيرًا أنك ما تأكله
هنا الخضار الورقية الداكنة مثل السبانخ
والكرنب يحتوي على
مضادات الأكسدة اللوتين والزياكسانثين التي
يبدو أنها تقلل من خطر التنكس البقعي المرتبط بالعمر ،
توصي الأكاديمية الأمريكية لطب العيون بإجراء فحص أساسي للعين يبدأ
في  سن 40. تأكد من حصولك على تلك الفحوصات التي
تُترك دون علاج ، فقد يؤدي
فقدان البصر إلى التدهور المعرفي حتى الخرف لأنه
كما قد تتخيل ، فإن الرؤية تحد من
المشاركة في الأنشطة البدنية والاجتماعية
التي يُعرف أنها مهمة
للوقاية من الخرف ، يمكنك سماع المزيد
عن كيفية القيام بذلك.  لتحسين صحتك
وحياة Chase أينما تحصل على
ملفاتك الصوتية